[Musique]
parti sur ce troisième quart de finale
de ce grand échec de bordeaux 2007
bonsoir merci merci donc voilà donc il
ya eu deux premiers quarts de finale cet
après midi il est dans le premier quart
d'heure les apéritifs aujourd'hui le
grand maître international
alberto david a battu difficilement au
tie break
il ya eu deux parties nulles dans les
parties de 20 minutes par joueur et
ensuite donc dans les blitz de départage
il a réussi à gagner est battue donc le
maître international yoann benita dans
le deuxième quart de finale et bien
laurent frayssinet sans surprise a battu
le champion d'aquitaine 2006 qui s'est
bien battu mais il a battu 2-0 le match
sans bavure mais il y avait il y avait
quand même un peu de flottement dans les
parties et on a failli assister à une
demi surprise on va dire voilà alors
troisième quart de finale ce soir
l'heure avant de passer de passer au
match proprement dit aux joueurs je vais
quand même vous pourrez expliquer le
principe du grand prix le grand prix
déchets de bordeaux c'est un événement
qui a pour objectif de vulgariser de jeu
d'échecs de le rendre le plus accessible
possible jeu d'échecs qui vous savez
peut-être et la deuxième fédération
mondiale avec 162 pays affiliés 6
millions de licenciés dans le monde à
peu près 600 millions de joueurs loisirs
à peu près 55 mille licenciés en france
et quelques millions de joueurs loisirs
dont certains sans doute parmi vous
alors pour suivre cet événement est bien
un écran géant ici donc ou l'échiquier
ici est reproduit le même et chic et sur
lequel joue les joueurs et avec le
système électronique en fait on va
pouvoir donc suivre les parties et la
partie en direct sur cet échiquier
on a le temps alloué aux deux joueurs
donc ce sont des parties semi-rapides un
match aller-retour en deux parties donc
avec les blancs et ensuite avec les
noirs pour équilibrer en cas d'égalité
donc des blitz de départage qui eux sont
départis de cinq minutes par joueur
le match donc se déroule au meilleur des
deux parties et donc avec retient lui
les visites se départagent voit le
principe
et si vous avez des casques évidemment
vous pourrez bénéficier des commentaires
que je n'en aurai moi même avec le
président de l'échiquier bordelais jean
reno lagune
grand amateur de jeux d'échecs très bons
joueurs de niveau national et qui va
commenter avec nous ces partis essayer
de vous faire comprendre les arcanes de
la pensée des champions alors pour ce
troisième quart de finale peut-être en
et match même sans doute oui un des deux
matchs les plus forts ce soir avec le
match qui suivra à 22h eva nous allons
recevoir deux champions d'exception
alors tout d'abord un jeune champion
il a 16 ans oui juste 16 ans champion de
france cadet l'an dernier et bien il a à
gagner dans la foulée pour la première
fois depuis très longtemps pour aux
jeunes français le titre de champion
d'europe des champions d'europe cadets
donc un très grand avenir échiquéen sans
doute il est donc déjà très très fort il
est déjà maître international
à 16 ans je vous demande d'applaudir et
d'encourager très fort notre jeune
champion national vient de poitiers
maître international romain et de larmes
et edward
[Applaudissements]
alors bon chemin
on peu tendu pour ce mois que je suppose
quand même un peu préparation un
champion d'europe ça se prépare comme
ans
[Musique]
son propre répertoire d'ouvertures ses
propres débuts de partie
voilà donc on dira pas plus parce que je
le sors un peu tendu je préfère qu'il
reste concentré sur sa partie alors face
à lui il va jouer l'un des meilleurs
joueurs du monde
et oui multiples champions d'afrique qui
nous vient du barreau qui le joue en
france donc licencié au club de
montpellier échec est donc un des mes
sens meilleur du joueur du monde depuis
depuis quelques années déjà il a été
finaliste de l'édition 2005 de ce grand
prix des chèques de bordeaux face aux
grands anatoli karpov qui l'a poussé à
l'ultime blitz de départage c'est dire
qu'il avait mené le match en partie
rapide il a fallu que karpov égaliser
ensuite il avait réussi aussi à le
pousser dans les beats jusqu'au dernier
dernier bis de départage donc il a
échappé de très peu il a manqué de très
peu la victoire face aux grands karpov
c'est donc un très très grand joueur
qu'on va voir encore ce soir à l'oeuvre
je vous demande accueillir très fort le
grand maître international hicham
hamdouchi challandes bauchi par contre
richard alors troisième grand prix donc
des échecs de bordeaux pour toi après
2005 2006 l'an dernier à vive allure
pour qui cette année oui cela fait
toujours plaisir de revenir sur scène
comme la literie j'ai essayé de
m'appliquer de faire de mon mieux
un champion d'europe cadets c'est
difficile de jouer tout ça est tendue
l'or va falloir être fort
malheureusement ne comprend plus que
respectée
voilà donc on va voir ça tout de suite
alors pour ce match pour accompagner ce
match je vais demander à un arbitre
national et international patrick besse
2 nous revient sur tf1 patrice besse
babbitt ce match là je vous laisse entre
ses mains merci stephen mesdames et
messieurs je vais vous rappeler un petit
élément important quand vous avez le
casque sur les oreilles vous ne vous
rendez pas bien compte mais vous avez
tendance à parler fort si vous discutez
les parties ou déranger les joueurs dont
je vous demanderais de ne pas discuter
pendant que les parties se déroulent on
nous allons tirer au sort des couleurs
pour ses deux premières parties en 20
minutes
soit renault
bonsoir donc nous voilà de retour pour
ce troisième match
si vous entendez lever la main voilà ça
y est donc il ya déjà des gens qui sont
alors là on va attendre que en fait que
le tirage au sort soit fip ce qui
évidemment là on à monsieur parti voir
des buts avec les noirs les monsieur
hamdouchi avec les blancs lors du match
précédent il faut attendre évidemment
que tout ça se met en place
la poignée de main que tous les amateurs
d'échecs
on va voir les rôles entre on y est
hicham hamdouchi face à romain edouard
super match à l'affiché n'est pas ça
devrait être une très belle partie
voilà c'est parti le pied au roi sa
révolte par la défense sicilienne
alors pour ceux qui découvrent ça va
souvent très vite au début parce que les
joueurs sont extrêmement bien préparé on
a là une défense sicilienne qui
caractérisait par le cou et 4 des blancs
et la réponse c'est 5 des noirs en ça
s'appelle comme ça c'est défense
sicilienne du nom des joueurs italiens
qui utilisait sa voile à l'école de la
renaissance
donc tout de suite la laci si elle
ouverte avec des 4 et s'éprend d4 et
cavaliers prendre et qu'il y avait un
échange ici sur cette case des quatre
ici ensuite et loire ont sorti leurs
cavaliers 9,6 pour forcer la sortie qui
a blessé trois ici donc ça c'est une
jeune nico flore que je connais très
très bien 1 renault voyez c'est une
variante moderne et qui se joue depuis
quelques années alors je technique aussi
une variante une souriante qu'on appelle
de l'estagnol soit céder non vous
laissez pas impressionner par l'énoncé
des noms comme ça qui sont donnés aux
vrais repas en général pour le nom des
joueurs qui les ont inventés
voilà c'est un grand maître russe
schennikov que le grand théoricien des
échecs qui a donné son nom à cette
souriante delà des six il y est voilà
parce qu'on peut jouer plein de
variantes après le coup c'est 5 et
notamment ici s'est caractérisé la
suisse qui courent par le coup eux cinq
joué très vite voilà et avec cette
caractéristique que souvent le cavalier
viennent si l'on revient sur cette case
alors à noter ici à ce qu'on appelle une
faiblesse
ça va être crucial s'est récemment pour
la partie voilà le cou blanc ici appuyé
sur cette faiblesse des 5 pourquoi parce
qu'il clôt le cavalier voyez le cavalier
ici ne peut pas bouger
évidemment ça va vite voilà le fou
attaque la dame donc si lecavalier bouge
il est la prise et comme lecavalier
défend la case des 5
c'est un coût qui indirectement joue
pour le contrôle de cette calme qui est
faible pour quoi et bien parce qu'il ya
plus de pions qui permettrait d'attaquer
une pièce ici sur cette case
donc c'est une case sur lequel on
pourrait mettre notamment le cavalier
c'est certainement d'ailleurs ce qui va
se passer maintenant
maintenant il prend d'abord on peut
aussi jouer cette variante
et voilà et maintenant le cavalier vient
sur la classe des 5
comme prévu donc ça c'est encore une
variante donc fou g7 ici jouée par mes
doigts on est dans la théorie ici ce
qu'on appelle la théorie les joueurs
connaissent très bien 7,7
cette ouverture très certainement je
savais pas que romain edouard était un
défenseur de set à nadal lors de la
flèche nikov donc l'aller les blancs une
forte case centrale avec le cavalier des
cinq installé non chassable par un pion
peut pas chasser peinture en soit les
blancs jouent ces 3 ou c4 éventuellement
et le cavalier à 3 violence et 2008
vient en pierre de 3 pour faire le
relais des cavaliers pour verrouiller
encore mieux cette case et que
lecavalier soit installé sur la case est
c'est fait alors laissez donc c'est
tristan d'arbres et la compensation des
baignoires évidemment qui en donnait 7
et cases aux pièces blanches réside par
la paire de fou voilà il ya la paire de
fou il ya de fous ici contre un seul est
de fous sont souvent ensemble permet de
défendre à long terme est ici plus tard
quand les pions disparu à long terme ici
les cases à la fois noire et blanche
dans une
couleurs parfois quand on a bien sûr le
fou comme ici le fond blanc on peut pas
contrôler à distance etc alors là ça
c'est thématique du jeu au service de la
paire de fou c'est à dire que les noirs
font éclater les pierres sans trop de
manière à ce que les fous et une
activité et ne soient pas gênés par
leurs propres pions il faut que leurs
pions soient mobiles ce qui est le cas
les pions noirs des 6 500 mobiles sauf
le pionner 6 pour l'instant le temps qui
les hoquets une faiblesse en tant qu il
est bloqué par le cavalier est décédé
cinq et on a vu voilà effectivement que
les noirs donc on échange et ont joué le
coup et 5 très vite pour les charger le
pion central 4 mai et maintenant ils ont
encore un deuxième pion qui va pouvoir
venir encore une fois au centre plus
tard sans doute c'est aussi souvent
thématiques tout ça et tout ça est assez
connu et ce cavalier 6 et 2 donc comme
on l'avait vu ça leur va venir sans
doute plus tard sur la case de 3 on peut
jouer même d'erreurs des fois la passe
de à la base comme cavalier 3 et par
exemple sur un coucou faut aussi sont
peu joué g4 avec l'idée de contrôler la
case fcn qui est d'empêcher le coup et
f5 des noirs c'est un peu tendu mais ça
peut jouer
alors attention évidemment on est là
face aux cavaliers 3 le coût normal le
cloud 9 ou se replie sur ce rejet 6 pour
garder une belle diagonale il garderait
une belle diagonale ici il aurait pu
venir à aussi souci il peut aussi venir
un dossier de manière à contrôler les
cases du cavalier de troie envoyé comme
ce cas les bouts mais d'un autre côté il
est à la fois beau mais il tape dans le
vide pour l'instant oui mais ce qu'ils
souhaitent c'est sans doute joué cinq
pour sortir le cavalier
le cavalier de 3 et que les cavaliers ne
soit plus lié de manière un jour pousser
des 5 et que les cavaliers ne trouve
plus de cazaux stable pour pour rester
voilà alors la position pour compenser
cette perte de fou effectivement alors
je vais leur expliquer un peu parce que
la route tu vas tu va beaucoup trop vite
sur mais c'est vrai tu as raison
effectivement l'idée effectivement comme
utiliser excel pour chasser ce cavalier
en fait parce qu'on menacerait f4 qui
attaque risque a lieu trois qui auraient
du mal à trouver une case sympathique il
est bien heureux 3 pas envie de le
bouger ce cavalier donc ça serait c'est
possible pour les noirs donc ces
thématiques
voilà une fois qu'on a fait exploser le
centre ici donc on toujours le jeu pour
le centre aux échecs notamment le pion
aux cadres donc a été échangé par aurier
le pion g7 avaient repris ici le
cavalier qui était attaqué par le fou
ensuite il est venu au f5 proposé un
échange sur quatre est maintenant qu'il
ya plus de 80 ou plus ramener encore un
pion f5 et donc on contrôle les cas
centrale les caisses des quatre cases de
carcasses très importante avec deux fous
très bien passé derrière donc romain
edouard adeptes ici un peu comme les
jeunes d'ailleurs en général de
positions extrêmement agressive et
ouverte et offert la crise les jeunes
c'est et ils n'ont pas peur voyons
l'énergie ils n'ont pas peur isr
l'énergie donc ils sont prêts à jouer
toutes positions ouvertes position
d'attaqué agressive et romain edouard
est un jeune qui calcule alors le tag
est un très fort tacticien bouchikhi un
coup responsable avec l'idée qu'ils
voulaient jouer à agen pour attaquer le
fou ensuite jouer h6 et titille encore
le fou et mettre un pion proche du roi
noir avec une tour active mais le
problème de ce plan évidemment ça aussi
dernier avantage c'est que ça dénude un
peu le côté de l'est le roi ici le côté
où habituellement les rois les blancs
pardon fond le petit rock comme les
noirs ici on fait le petit rock alors le
petit rebond rappelle peut peut-être
pour les amateurs aussi pour les jeunes
ya beaucoup de jeunes ce soir qui sont
venus
non le petit rock c'est simplement le
roi de deux cases de côté et la tour par
l'insu lorsque l'espace elle sera
libérée c'est à dire lorsque les deux
pièces mineurs entre l'euro et les
retours auront quitté la première à
travers ce voile à noter donc il ya des
jeunes d'aujourd'hui notamment qui sont
invités par notre partenaire notamment
le conseil général et aussi évidemment
le conseil régional qui soutient les
deux collectivités qui soutiennent cet
événement depuis le début et l'ensemble
de nos partenaires privés aussi qui sont
présents dans le programme officiel du
grand prix si vous n'avez pas le
programme officiel il doit en rester à
l'accueil si vous souhaitez en avoir
donc ces jeunes ces jeunes joueurs qui
suivent des cours dans les écoles
notamment par partons que le oui mais ce
qui est bordelais donnent des cours dans
les collèges les écoles de bordeaux et
puis au club évidemment pour former des
jeunes aussi découvrir des jeunes
talents on a tous envie de découvrir les
futurs wifi développer les qualités d'un
joueur
les qualités propres joue des chèques et
ça développe aussi des qualités
indéniables
la concentration nouvelles venues
notamment le jeu d'échecs est devenu
d'ailleurs officielle depuis le 15
février voilà reconnu une part le
ministère de l'éducation si ça c'est
important aussi c'est assez nouveau
cette année
voilà leur fout d'eux a été jouée par
hicham hamdouchi développement il faut
développer ces pièces aux échecs
on profite du fait que le cavalier ou
trois protège encore le pion g2 est
attaqué par ce fou oui le blanc des
retards développement là il avait encore
infos sur la première traverse il avait
par ok il n'avait pas terminé
c'est un début là encore des pièces à
mettre en jeu
c'est curieux ce coup fout d'eux puisque
ce coup faut donner il semble pas en
relation et le coiffeur en fait l'idée
de l'idée du couffo 2 c'est de jouer il
faut être trois pour changer ou de
l'info pour casser la paire de foule
siens hausse il peut éliminer on est de
fou noir pour éliminer ce fou lancé la
fameuse bière bien fouillé sur les
débats ce noir avec le fou g7 les cases
blanches avec le fond blanc ces deux
fous ballaigues l'échiquier donc il veut
éliminer un des deux fous veulent et
miné
de manière à rester avec sa pièce
centrale belge à sable par les pions qui
fera qu'il sera bien installée qui
compensera le déséquilibre des pièces
mineurs qui restreint c'est à dire faut
qu'entre cavaliers alors le problème
c'est que bon on se fout totalement sauf
si l'idée de vraies fausses 3 et pas de
faire petit rock parce que si on fit
petit rock ne pas oublier que la dame
des huit ici viendrait pouf bien tu es
web et le pion à gratuitement rapidement
ce qui ne serait plus défendue par la
tourbe à twitter
donc c'est pas un coup pour une petit
rock est une menace qui n'est pas
négligeable cf3 f3 qui attaquent le fou
attaque le fou ce fou ne peut pas se
replier est obligé de s'échanger contre
le carrier les cinq puisque si leurs
vannes en f5 et bien le cavalier le
mange et silver angers 6 et bien le pian
h4 fait ça en rolls et avancent en âge 5
pour capturer le faux qui serait
enfermée par les pions alors peut-être
de pareilles occasions va montrer la
case ici g6 le four revient ici et le
pion attaquerait le fou qui n'aurait
plus de cases
donc après le coup et froid mais il
aurait pu faire tout de suite ce qu aux
3 1
donc pourquoi ne l'at il pas fait et il
n'a pas fait le coffret f3 parce que il
y aurait eu sans doute et f5
non s'il avait joué au lieu de jouer
fraude aussi des jouets f3 oui et bien
il y aurait eu avec cinq chinois on
laisse le fond non le le fou n'était pas
là le faux étaient en feu 6 il faut 4 et
leurs familles sur x 4 d'aquin so foot
quand les noirs joyau de l'art
tu as raison il aurait pu jouer f3 tout
de suite tu as raison obligeant le fou à
s'échanger donc je ne suis pas sûr
qu'ils après fou aux deux il veut y
jouer
3 parce que ça boucherait le faux deux
donc c'est peut-être pas son idée je
pense sinon le rejouer tout de suite
devrait jouer tout de suite fait pour
être joué tout de suite c'est bizarre
c'est pour ça je comprends pas ce qu'on
en fait j'aurais pas le comprendre sauf
à jouer pour les soins 3 x 3 pour
changer variable et f3 très affaibli les
cases noires est en fait l 3 n'était pas
un coup développement et donc il va il
faut aussi qu'ils pensent à sortir ses
pièces mois il veut préfère sortir ses
pièces et ses changé mais bon c'est vrai
que le même côté le coût et de temps
aurait forcé la prise du cavalier
puisque le fou
en effectivement f5 était en prise quand
tu mènes le dire et angers 6 se heurter
aux simples h5 qui attaquent le fou qui
n'aurait alors plus de plus de cases bon
donc la réflexion de correction des
doigts rayon des doigts parce que des
fois que l'on à une otan surpris que moi
du coup font eux deux alors est-ce que
le couffo de est une préparation il ya
moins de chic elle est peut-être aurons
mais il doit réfléchir à l'idée de
diamant oui parce que peut-être l'idée
sur france 3 c'est que sur fou que
prendre cavalli pour en prendre du fou
aussi aussi reprendre lui faut clore le
cloud cavaliers c6 sur la tournée ccisc
loire le pied en l'afsset
on va rappeler ce que c'est un clouage
henry alors un clouage c'est donc une
pièce
imaginons ensemble en arriver arriverez
sur cette case oui à une pièce à
l'emporter dam tour ou un fou qui au
travers d'une d'une pièce adverse vise
une pièce de plus grande valeur qui est
derrière
derrière elle sur la même ligne que le
succès soit une diagonale une une
traverse ou une win colonnes et donc les
cloisons ya donc de clouage le clouage
absolue car c'est le roi qui est la
pièce derrière et le cloître relatif
quand c'est une pièce de plus grande
valeur jean retour entre cavaliers ou
dame contrefoutent voilà entre en classe
et en classe ce serait un clouage
relatif sur le cavalier relative donc si
on bouge lecavalier et bien on perd la
tour en perd la tour mais là aux échecs
quelquefois on sait très bien que enfin
de très loin de ça et là quelques couacs
parce que ce cavalier la normale en à
tour ça c'est interdit
le cavalier que sur ces cases l'annoncé
pour le cas où
voilà donc la ami l'a pris et l'a pris
tout de suite oh mais c'est bizarre il
n'a pas laissé faire fausse 3 ide après
tout de suite oui il veut pas que le fou
s'active sur la sur la grande diagonale
il a l'air d'être très conséquent c'est
le roumain edward oui
donc là il prend ses responsabilités
l'un là il y aura sans doute qu'elle va
lier prendre puisque car il prend on
voit mal la dame
iran la dame et le dessin est le plus
mauvais les bloqueurs pour bloquer le
pion le pion je pense qu'il ya une idée
simple je pense qu'on nous sort d'un me
prends c'est que cet impact la dame et
ensuite des cinglés ensuite été
complètement libérée le les pions se
libère en avance 1 n'ont plus qu'à
l'écran on a remplacé une cagoule et par
les deux voiliers lamaneurs août à
l'heure le carré des terrains 3 il est
venu ici il est venu ici est donc
maintenant que l'échangé fait il
remplace donc le voyez cavaliers
interchangeables mais là la position au
point de vue matériel c'est complètement
équilibré c'est l'équilibré puis suivant
depuis le début tout à faut contrefout
cavaliers quand cavaliers et puis les
pièces lourdes alors contre lui il ya
quand même un léger déséquilibre encore
c'est que les fous ne semble pas de même
couleur
un des joueurs possèdent un fou de cases
blanches et l'autre possède le fou de
cases noires alors ça c'est un premier
sas est un facteur qui joue plutôt pour
l'attack voilà le fait que les fous
souhaitent qu'on leur posait deuxième
facteur important c'est la case des cinq
qui fort pour le cavalier est donc
derrière le pion des si ce qu'on appelle
un pion arriérés pian et terriere c'est
à dire que imaginons que les blancs
masse des pièces sur la colonne alors
sur cette colonne ici bonjour et dames
detroit ont joué ensuite tour d un puits
et ensuite quand on enlève le cavalier
hop le pion des six cb il valait bien
les fragiles
il va être mangé par anticipées si on
n'a pas défendu par avance
il a peut-être pouvoir se faire défendre
risqués ou contre-attaqué par ailleurs
et en général d'ailleurs c'est souvent
ce qui se passe et alors ça c'est un
facteur non plus tous ces facteurs
plutôt avantage des blancs par contre
lantages des noirs c'est la force du fou
du foot et cette foulée c'est le pion
aux simples depuis on ne sait que peu
avancé à tout moment parce qu'il n'est
pas bloquer le lancer et il peut se
faire soit de venir voir le pion f5
donc ça fait quand même et avions
centrales pour les noirs qu'on fait
voilà il ya 2 et depuis on sent trop de
lenteur c'est tout cela et où le simple
qui est le pur 5
et ça c'est bien sûr ce fou le g7
il lorgne à travers ou alors ça nous
courons à schwyz oui c'est pour un
obtenir laquelle g8 pour les tours
puisque la colonne ne l'oublions pas est
ouverte au noir il ya plus de cuir noir
sur cette table est ce que c'est pas
plutôt un coût qui est vite
des éventuels problèmes sur cette
diagonale quand les noirs jouent f5
oui aussi oui c'est un coup
prophylactique on appelle ça c'est un
coup prophylactique d'élire un coup
prophylactique on applique tout souvent
ça aux échecs la prophylaxie c'est l'art
de paris les menaces avant même qu'elles
existent et puis aussi il faut se dire
que le roi blanc devra un jour choisir
un une adresse donc s'il veut prendre
domicile sur l'as le roi est bien la
colonne âgées pourraient être ses voies
d'accès ils ne voient l'accès pour
l'attaquer pour l'attaqué et leur côté
semblent eux évidemment s'il va
s'abriter grand roque le fou est déjà
tout ce fric bien passé bien placé pour
l'accueillir une attaque avec les pions
qui sont déjà prêts à faire des ruptures
les pions en b alors ça des ruptures ses
larmes pouces rebecca voilà la c3 pour
casser ces trois et pour attaquer et on
mettrait une tour sur la colonne bea ça
y est la structure ouvrir des lignes
d'attaqué comme ça voilà donc position
très très très ouverte
ah oui avec un petit potentiel oui
comment faire les blancs que de le roi
qu'est ce qu'il va en faire de leurs
droits alors à noter un autre facteur
quand même on n'a pas une fusion des six
faible pour les noirs donc on voit que
les noms de l'activité en échange de ça
il ya un autre point qui favorise les
blancs c'est le les îlots de pions on va
noter ici que l îlot de pion à 2b 2c 3
un îlot f2 j'ai 2 h 2 ça fait deux îlots
dernière dépliant un leader on a des
pions en lisant et les noix en ont 3
donc ça s'est moins bien parce que ça
fait autant de cibles
chaque kilo d'opium est une cible voilà
et leurs pieds est possible dans son
propre camp depuis on est susceptible de
se faire vers ciblées c'est le cas de le
dire voilà alors les à l'aise qu'il ya
trois îlots voiliers de alors sur le pib
22e sur les d eux ah mais non fo ci est
le troisième illoul c'est le salon le
pion isolé voilà le tueur isolé alors
bien sûr
le premier joueur important qui avait et
compris des techniques de jeu des pions
c'était le fameux le fameux ambrée
danican philidor qui lui il va expliquer
comment jouer les pions louis-andré d'un
étang fils d'or et donc ceux se ses
joueurs français de l'époque de louis 15
oui 18e 15h16 il il a été important dans
l'histoire et dans la compréhension des
échecs tous un grand musicien
oui c'était un musicien important qui
était le premier créé à l'opéra comique
français est donc ici le lit des deux
des trois îlots c'est simplement qu'il y
a plus de cibles comme disait stéphane
c'est à dire que chaque îlot le pion à
sa base qui est fragile par exemple le
pion à 6 c'est la base donc une cible le
pian des six la base du deuxième îlot
qui est fragile où le pion à m7 et
puisque là il ya deux pions qui sent
l'arrière de cette minichaîne là puisque
elle n'est pas encore établie la chaîne
atteint que le pion à vii et à l'arrière
et puis le pion isolé qui est aussi est
une cible chez les blancs les cibles
sont les pions de base de la phalange si
elle existait il appelait ça les
phalanges philidor les phalanges de
pions donc le pion h4 si le pion blanc
par exemple j'ai de 20 g iii ce sera le
pion f2 qui sera la cible qui sera le
kiosque qui sera la base et le pion
faible et de l'autre côté ce sera le
pion de base qui sera le plus en fait
donc deux cibles de faiblesse depuis un
an chez les blancs et +22 donc 3 ou
presque 4 puisqu'il ya deux pions pour
le pour la chaîne du milieu voilà donc
il vous tour ses huit pour ses 8
évidemment il domina la fameuse colonne
c'est de la sicilienne d'amd de aussi
cher donc ici ménages de faire le manque
ou le petit rock mais bleu petit rôle
n'est pas conseillée avant à cause d'un
proche 4 quoique
ce serait tout de suite je la colonne
ouverte pour l'attak alors quand la
particularité aussi le match d'après on
verra le match rené contre cornette
oui et bien au lit rené et l'entraîneur
de romain edouard oui donc c'est olivier
rhône et qui entraîne romain edouard
donc ce nouveau grand espoir français
champion d'europe donc olivier rhône et
qu'on verra à 22h face à notre premier
maître international bordelais matthieu
cornette qui a notamment était
l'entraîneur de enfin qu'a fait partie
de l'équipe d'anatolie karpov lors de ce
championnat face à kas part au concours
medouar un super entraîneur bien sûr oui
oui ok on est un joueur d'expérience en
plus exactement ce qu'il fait et qui est
un excellent joueur un des meilleurs
français il a menacé plusieurs fois les
champions de france 1 terminant second
en étendant les dans les premiers alors
là l'idée de tours c'est 8
donc c'est un jour d'envahir la case c4
c'est-à-dire de poster le cavalier c6
sur laquelle ces 4 à 5 et ensuite ses
cartes voilà attentats canada mais ça
c'est anecdotique c'est surtout pour
pour
que ce cavalier soif autrement installée
puisque si on veut le chasser il faudra
jouer b3 et donc fragilisé le pion sait
s'ils ont joué trois bombes pour chasser
le cavalier et ses cartes c'est ce
qu'ils ont l'air bien faible voilà alors
on appelle ça des cases d'avant postes
alors qu'il anticipe et bien sûr hicham
ne veut pas que que ce cavalier puissent
facilement aller sur la grande poste
alors que thématique mains juge unique
au fait qu à quatre voilà donc on
attaque cette phalange de pions voilà
l'idée c'est que si les noirs prennent
ici
les blancs ont le choix entre tout
reprendre 4 est aussi fou prend 1,6
voyez que le plus raciste devient faible
donc et si les noirs prennent à 4 même
tour prend 1,4 et le pion à six a du mal
a défendu et et la case la fameuse case
c4 d'avant de postes sur la colonne
ouverte dont il n'a plus la même vallée
la plus belle la vie d'avoir des valeurs
parce qu'elle est les voix soutenue par
le pion qui l'attaquent eu le soutien de
la casse etc a donc tout de suite ils
s'organisent pour pour lutter contre le
plan noir par contre c'est clair il
refera plus de ce côté là ils visitent
difficile là maintenant il y aura trop
de lignes ouvertes donc il faudra mettre
le roi là mais pour l'instant tant que
le pion à ce cap difficile
ce serait en voie là ce serait ok côté
cimetière n'appelle donc ici vote il va
par ok sur le grand rouquin avec le four
à quai la tour mais parti alors il faut
noter le temps évidemment c'est du chaos
cette partie donc il reste neuf minutes
40 exactement et 9 minutes 10 à rome les
douanes 40 affiche à mende douche il a
fallu dix armée doit si un joueur part
malheur arrivait à 0 secondes
il aurait perdu la partie donc ça oblige
les joueurs à jouer à une cadence
importante élevé donc peut-être on
notera par rapport aux deux premiers
matches
il me semble renault que les joueurs
gèrent mieux leur temps que ce qui
réfléchissent plus dans les coûts
importants oui et sur l'ouverture tant
qu'aidant une ouverture
ici il ya presque une minute d'avancé
pour pour hicham c'est la différence
aussi mais bon c'est pas indicatif là il
est en train de revenir et c'est il a le
très réfléchi mais l'instinct par contre
très bien joué de la part de on est noir
bien sûr il ne peut plus utiliser la
case et d'avant de postes donc qu'il va
essayer de viser autre chose dit c'est
simplement d'échanger ce qu'avait des
cinq pénible bien sûr parce que si les
changes s'est laissé le thème expliqué
par parme in the beach lorsque votre
adversaire a un bon bloqueur
il faut essayer d'expulser le bloqueur
de la case de sa case de blocage alors
par contre le souci une autre idée
peut-être qui peut être intéressante que
je veux dire dans cette position c'est
que peut-être il visera après le coup b5
a fragilisé la case des 4 et peut-être y
est installé un cavalier sur cette case
des quatre par le coup cavaliers f5 des
quatre quelque chose comme ça en ayant
au passage le tempo sur le pion h qui
seraient attaqués de faire des crises
que voilà et puis récupéré la case des
quatre dans ce sens par la voix la
mélancolie belleville en est le nom d
bien sûr mais je parlais avec avec des
400 m en salle pour là pour attaquer la
chaîne
oui oui mais un jour et c'est ça peut
être un des objectifs parce que le cav
il est le premier objectif ici du coup
cavalia 7
et de toute façon des charges et le
bloqueur voilà alors le problème voilà
c'est que ça perd le pion baissé voilà
donc alors ça c'est un coup responsable
parce que là le pion mais c'est qu'ils
aient perdu voilà et s'il est noir
reprennent est tout simplement fou
prendre les 5 gagnants pions donc mais
mais c'est vrai que les blancs ghanim
tueur mais d'un autre côté ils ont par
ok nantes a enduré par le pion à siroki
pearl pirates 4 ça veut dire que l'heure
tourne et un jeune est donc pour
l'instant c'est tournez pas en jeu donc
romain edouard a estimé que ça valait
bien un pion alors est ce que tous ceux
ci viennent une préparation que je
remets edwards aurait fait avec olivier
rené c'est possible attention je ne sais
pas rond l'intention mais bon il cherche
c'est toujours pas le dernier à se
préparer c'est très c'est toujours très
difficile d'évaluer aux échecs ce que
vaut le sacrifice d'un pion par rapport
aux aux compensations que l'on obtient
en tout cas c'est une belle partie entre
les joueurs bien dans la partie bien
concentré faudra juste que il oublie pas
d'accélérer le rythme quand le temps
deviendra critique pour l'instant ce
n'est pas encore le cas mais ne pas
oublier ça parce que sinon évidemment et
c'est la finesse d'analysé des wade des
joueurs qui étaient qu'ils sont capables
de
d'estimer les compensations matérielles
contre contre autre chose ligne attaque
possibilité ultérieure etc kasparov
quand il était jeune très souvent donné
un pion dans ces parties pour avoir eu
même quand tu pourras oui on priera pour
avoir un jeu de pièces agréable et libre
laprise prises dont qui charge le
bloqueur la dame deviennent blogueurs
c'est le plus mauvais des bloqueurs il
va sans doute jouer pour ces 5 c'était
son idée je pense voilà devenir tour ses
seins voilà avec l'idée après je vous
prends les gens et la tour protège voilà
oui c'est parce que c'est bien ce que
pense que tu essaies c'était une idée
bien sûr donc il a réalisé le thème
thématique des noirs qui étaient
expulsion du bloqueur par contre il ya
plus les cavaliers donc il reste les
pièces lourdes et les fous de couleurs
opposées
ce qui veut dire qu'en cas d' échange de
pièces lourdes ans pourrait s'orienter
vers une partie nulle puisque les fous
de couleurs opposées favorise les impôts
restent en position les prix sont là
s'attaquer à ce lourd de sens la
favoriser la taxe c'est à dire quand la
table sur une couleur et l'autre sur
l'autre cool par exemple des trois dames
4 et s'est tout de suite et problème un
noir ne sert à rien bien sûr paris cette
menace donc ça oblige les noirs à
utiliser d'autres types de mai sans que
le pion f5 peut défendre alors la
diagonale mais c'est le genre d'idée oui
peut très bien faire mouche
en tout cas là il faut savoir que faire
de cette dame
alors il doit hésiter à aller en baisse
est pour nous soit pour regarder le
matériel voilà parce que si l'on prend
on peut quand même prendre du poil elle
le fait bien sûr il joue à 17 pour
garder le matériel mais il va sans doute
prendre et puis il aura il aura là
ça t'en fou prend là bien sûr il aura la
colonne b il aura la colonne b ensuite
avec le pion b à la traîne la dame
amazon sur la colonne qu a indiqué
renaud donc l'idée effectivement ce que
tu vois ce que tu penses que tu me
racontes là c'est que après vous prend
par exemple pour pour jouer deux des
cinq ans huit dames des six est ensuite
la tour ici on met vite
oui il parlera pas non plus de donner
trop de pions faut pas trop de données
le pian l7 profite d'un séjour à paris
la dame pour être qu'il faut il faut pas
trop en donner mais alors on pourra
peut-être ses organes ou attaqué sur ses
moyens pour attaquer sur cette colonne
voix l'attaqué plombé de voilà enfin
l'internaute tout de suite c'est pas
possible
donc il nous faut prendre il s'accroche
à son matériel il ya toujours cette
histoire de payer une compensation c'est
qu' il ne peut toujours pas roquettes
coelho h4 en l'air oui à l'époque il ya
toujours ce pion qui est en l'air c'est
sale c'est oui voilà c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure quel est le sens
de la compensation kona pour ceux qui on
est bien la compensation ici c'est le
retard de développement les blancs les
pièces en parts sont pas coordonnés pour
gagner un pion général quand on veut
gagner du matériel comme ça eh bien on
n'a pas ces pièces coordonnées on a ces
pièces qui s'égare un peu sur
l'échiquier dans le matériel le plus
mais souvent on peut le payer
bien qu on a pris deux pions bessem le
fou n'est pas très actif en bessin
maintenant voilà mais des joueurs comme
kornoi eux ne s'arrêtait pas à saïlgoh
tel matériel et ensuite il le digérer et
gagner la partie
on attend quand même de romain edouard
renault tout simplement le coût des cinq
protégé par la dame desservies par
légèrement rabroué la menace des quatre
protégé par le fouet aux groupes y ont
passé et qui va rendre le fou puissant
qui rend le fou puissant plus ça va
casser le pion ces trois ans enfin tout
cas des cinq semble le coup logique si
les blancs peuvent le faire alors
évidemment des cinq finales et blanc
pourrait aussi les noirs pour se heurter
un bon tour d un simple et donc on a un
joueur créatif là
romain edouard actifs ces pièces en
libre bien organisés et il a donné un
plan oui jouer quatre passes qui est
mieux il veut jouer eux trois
alors non il veut il veut attaquer le
fameux roi rester au sahara faut
expliquer à nos spectateurs ainsi un
spectateurs et téléspectateurs
oui ici dam des clients ont apparemment
d'un champion si tu apprends pions et
bien on perd la dame en cause deux tours
donc pas tours 8 par saskia le fou et le
5 mai tour 5 des photos celles sans
compter que le foot le foot des cinq
étant prises
oui mais tour st gall et la drame
étaient cloués sur le roi voilà c'est à
dire que la dame pouvait pas bouger
parce qu'ils ont un échec avec la tour
voilà donc ça de gagné la dame est donc
se secoue de pian là c'est le et d un
coût très perturbateurs parce qu'il a
joué que 3 pour ouvrir des lignes autour
du rôle du roi blanc qui restait au
centre peut-être pour casser la défense
voilà il est au centre
il veut fragiliser le roi blanc il faut
qu'ils jouent une partie très dynamique
puisqu'il ya du matériel à moi il a
donné un pion c'est un joueur qui a un
sens tactique aiguille moi je les ai vus
l'été dernier aux championnats de france
où il a survolé l'accession aussi est
maintenant aussi c'est possible d'un
tournoi les joueurs aguerris
le pr 9,5 c'est que les blancs pour
jouer le coutour à 7 avec la menace ici
dang tran phu g7 matt donc qui serait
bon qu'on pourrait parler avec les
normes et qui est quand même pénible
avec deux pièces très bien placé sur la
septième rangée
donc je pense pas qu'il va jouer le
simple nom il n'y a pas urgence à jouer
f5
mais il peut jouer alors qu'est-ce qu'il
peut jouer d'autres il pourrait jouer
des tours aux 5 pour mettre une tour au
centre
il pourrait aussi tout de suite joué 3 3
tout de suite joué trois pour affaiblir
les cases noires à l'entourage du foie
une fois que le pion que le pion greffe
a disparu la case g3 n'existe plus
elle est faible elle est pour les élèves
pour les noirs on peut en profite donc
ça donnerait accès mais le fou à 9,5 la
dame qui vit un f6 qui se met devant le
fou après 9,4 et qui remplace yann échec
oui oui et puis la tour qui est prête à
intervenir non il ya d'énormes
compensations pour le client la
possibilité pour une horde joué que
trois cas c'est un peu le l'entourage du
roi blanc menaces pointent deux échecs
ce pion il le récupèrera totsi les
blancs aux pires n'a pas d'avenir s'est
tjrs bien jouer trois ou f4 ce pionner 3
devient un poison qui est comme une
grosse épine dans le camp blanc donc il
faudrait prendre ce pion et on voit bien
que la du coup ça ça déstabilise
l'entourage du roi blanc qu'il ya
beaucoup de trop il ya notamment
effectivement cette mini diagonale avec
un kit échec poussé oui donc le le noir
la vallée c'est qu'il faut quand même
pouvoir profiter donc ils royal culé
donc là il y avait un suédois
il calcule mais à vue de nez comme ça on
peut penser que l'année commence à sion
oui ça sert à comprendre ces tronches la
victoire oui petit à petit que rinne
superbe coup du récipient prend fou
prend un échec et en avant prend la tour
1 il le fait il le fait c'était une des
forces des chefs et maintenant on
récupère la tour oui oui c'était une des
forces en mai mais la position reste la
mission mais tout vu et maintenant 4
la position reste reste égale trois
pions de l'autre on est une combinaison
qui ne fait que récupérer le matériel on
abrège moi je sais que j'aurais préféré
jouer 3 pour pour attaquer le roi parce
qu'il reste avec ses trois pions ces
trois pions isoler le noir il ya trois
pions isolé mais mais il ya toujours les
footeux couleurs opposées qui favorise
la tacc maintenant tour huit salles de
gestion par contre il a une pièce de
plus en activité cette tour là ne joue
pas la tour est un ajout pas extrêmement
dynamique ce que vient de faire
romain edouard j'ai complètement oublié
ce coup
incroyable tout repenser 3 et pourtant
non mais c'est un coût qui comme sa part
est terrible mais je l'aurais préférée
trois temps a préféré le coup
oui mais avec peut-être pas de
compensation aussi au site l'air aussi
clair en tout cas là il a égalisé au
matériel il a quand même un gros pions
pas cédé 6-1 au nom oui là il a un plan
parcellaire
il avait passé un village on sait mais
ça y est mais très vite voilà voilà
il va s'organiser on protège f4 h4
pardon à les suivre
il a l'oeil et il a le défenseur naturel
des cases blanches qui est le fou le
case blanche bureaux et 2 donkey chamakh
est ce qu'il va faire il va faugeron il
va pouvoir jouer roigé deux fois chez
toi libérer ses atours et sortir la tour
enfin pour essayer d'arrêter ceux qui
ont passé sans doute bon il faudra faire
attention mais j'ai quand même sentiment
qu'elle voir son mieux - avec ceux qui y
ont passé la maintenant attention c'est
vrai que laurent noir peuvent rêver
aussi s'avérer faible plus tard tu en
voilà il officia mais il fait chaud en
f3 il va jouer
pourquoi il fait froid parce que si
jouer roger de tout de suite il y avait
tout un jeu de mail avantages du fou ici
c'est que sur roy g2 il n'y a pas
d'échec sur cette grande diagonale tant
que le fou là il protège
voilà donc dans la lah il faut jouer il
faut absolument jouer d'amener un métis
qui les ont mis la grille 6e romain
edouard avait toujours infernale il est
toujours comme ça attention puisque la
tour c'est un joueur qui va peut-être
pouvoir faire en échec sur les
responsabiliser ces pièces
donc là peut-être en plus jouer d'âme
des uns visible et tant pis si son
peuple à l'échec il va changer l'image
charge les tours et puis voilà voilà il
va il va sans doute maintenant essayer
de faire nul d'annuler cette par contre
avec les foules couleurs contraire bon
ça y est la dame attaque si on attaque
la dame tacle qui on excepte oui mais on
s'attend un coup comme moi je parie pour
un coup comme d'hab cette voie là
d'amsterdam cette protège le pion à vii
et en même temps menacé d'un monsieur
d'un moins cher que tu pourrais pas
vraiment pas une vraie menace d'ailleurs
mais bon
roger 2 pour hicham en laye l'empêchent
l'échec fou des quatre ans il a encore
eu la cible
le corps est depuis peu il peut menacer
damas damon pour me la sécurité mais bon
mais blanc pour le protéger comme il
peut aller vers le protège france voilà
donc bon et puis les blancs équilibre
ouais équilibre petit avantage blanc par
la structure là et quand même plus
solide que la structure n'en voyez qu'il
est complètement éclaté oui mais comment
voilà c'est surtout les fautes que leur
opposer si il suffit que les dames soit
échangé pour ça soit nul oui dommage
qu'il ait qu'il n'ait pas joué notre
suite
il suffit que les dames soit échangé
pour que ce soit nul belle partie quand
même un très très agressif si romain
edouard fait nul comme sa baignoire il
prend un petit ascendant psychologique
sur les matchs quartiers typiques des
jeunes joueurs c'est à dire partie
ouverte ça c'est la partie typiquement
il voyage parlant du match on sait les
noirs jouent avec lui il joue avec les
noirs mais sans fermer en ayant fait
peur quand même un peu riches allouaient
il a il faut un petit ascendant bien sûr
ça veut dire qu'avec les blancs tout à
l'heure si les actifs
il a joué pour gagner le match donc les
pressions sur les charges oui hicham
c'est vrai qu'alors on peut parler
tirage au sort c'est sans doute trop
mengue edward kelly ni tirage j'ai passé
mais en général le choix osé regarder le
temps trois minutes 5,40 effectivement
contre une 36,36 peut-être qu'ils
veulent travailler un peu autant il va
travailler autant voilà faudrait pas que
romain edouard maintenant tombe autant
il faut qu'il joue il faut et c'est vrai
qu'il faut que je joue vite et il ya une
grosse et car attention et moi en
effectivement tu as raison d'un échec
d'un mètre 5
pas facile madame st voilà bon il va
faire débat et c'est le fait de se faire
mal
je pense que du sud parce que cette
partie va se terminer par l'annulation
temps soyez pas très élégant de poser
les gants de gagner une partie
autant comme ça c'est quand même un
tournoi est d'accord quand même tournoi
donc tissé pression quand même avec dame
est fou il s'était pression sur les
cases blanches
donc attention medouar autant oui vous
avez vu les deux joueurs se sont
organisés pour mettre leurs pièces un
attaque d'une cible il faut minutes 8
c'est chaud quand même très vives il a
deux minutes d'avancé c'est énorme et il
peut le travailler un petit peu c'est ce
qui ce qui est en train de faire il joue
son match à francky va travailler autant
si le grignote doucement et il est gagné
cette partie au temps mais ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils la gagnent sur
l'échiquier par un appareil de
démonstration technique belle partie
comme une robe noire très jolie
simplification pour autant ces trois
condamnés pas vu d'autre possibilité d'
attaque et finalement donc il a récupéré
ses pions et là bon effectivement moins
moins bonnes structures de pions 1 trois
îlots comme ça contre un seul mais foot
me reposer donc gros gros gros facteur 2
nuls la seule chose qui peut aider là
encore les blogs à nice et garder les
dames
oui si j'allais à main disparaissent
c'est une nulle
ouais il faut que les blancs garde les
dames se servent de leurs deux leurs
pions pour pour attaquer encore le roi
noir est bon regardez comme rob edwards
il faut qu'il joue très vite
oui il va y va jouer oui parce qu'il
veut jouer tous les coups à tempo il a
compris que hicham veulent travailler
autant est donc très vite deux images où
enfant il va il va essayer de faire des
ruptures avec les pieds en écriture il
faut pas oublier qu'il a trois contre
deux ça y est
romain edouard va essayer de faire un
perpétuel derrière il a essayé de faire
un petit perpétuelle tout faire péter
alice y faire quelque chose alors qu'est
ce qu'il va faire il réfléchit trop
longtemps il a une minute de retard et
mis lé feu qui joue vite une minute on
va avoir des soucis là il faut pas
qu'ils se laissent à grignoter là il est
en train de se laisser grignoter ouais
il va perdre autant j'ai très peur pour
lui l'un 44 secondes où c'est très très
dur et qui charment joue avec eux voyons
l'expérience des vieux briscards
attention à la fuite la fuite s'était
matt donc il faut jouer royal était
peut-être maintenant attention sur
qu'est-ce qui passeront f3 menace se
nomme des huit échecs suivi de suroît et
5 kg 4 mat
regardez bref 3 imaginons clairoix nord
joue pas et fait roi f3 pour les ti ces
deux régions il avait nommé cheikh
menaces et sur les variations
donc il était samedi laissant croire et
le travail il le travaille avec son
petit en-avant sur cette voie là où il
faut 4 c'est très dur c'est trop dur il
va 30 secondes en fait il est il est
dominé la roma edward c'est très très
dur à défendre c'est très très dur en
défendant fait aller il faut des acteurs
nul possible sur les couleurs opposées
oui aussi à batna mais la structure de
pions et la difficulté de défendre cette
position mais cette position
indéfendable avec du temps et on est
bien d'accord
et william a l'habitude de ces grands
prix de parties rapides ou le temps
compte presque autant qu'une pièce une
minute d'avancé dans ces tournants là ça
vaut presque autant qu'une pièce à la
proposition d'échangé dames et il adore
n'a pas beaucoup de cases il faut aller
en rage cet échec en fuite
et si des changes les dames c'est nul
c'est sûr mais il est en train de
descendre lui même autant je pense que
dans ce jeu parce que des qui dès qu'il
arrivera à son niveau il va lui proposer
car les cadets qui va arriver après
c'est vital
medouar oui mais là il faut alors même
si la haye échange ça y est chargé
chance voilà je tends cellule je pense
que les joueurs vont pas aller jusqu'au
bout c'est nul ça va passer en 19
secondes rôles assez chaud quand même
oui mais cessé de tourner sa fermeture
en b oui ferrand pions mais oui mais
c'est peut-être nuit quand même gros
c'est aujourd'hui mais ça c'est nul
voila il va prendre le pion mais c'est
une position connue pour être une
position 2 nuls
18 15 14 ils vont jusqu'au bout
maintenant c'est hicham kemal il fait un
peu la paire rotor en ayant voulu faire
le malin mais cette partie en ayant
voulu faire le malin il est parti il va
la perdre autant à 5 secondes et eloi
est déçu on a mis tout le monde est là
nul il peut demander le nul il vaut
mieux qu'il ya demande parce qu'il m'a
permis tort tant que ça y est il a
demandé la nulle je crois qu'ils entrent
ils ont fait nul à une seconde là là et
il a joué avec le feu et chats mais ça
fait il y retourner le sud c'est chaud
et bien après une lutte acharnée venait
d'assister à ce qu'on appelle une nulle
aux deux combattants entre monsieur
hamdouchi et monsieur et doit nous
allons nous arrêter pendant cinq minutes
le temps de tout remettre en place et
nous allons repartir avec les couleurs
opposées
je vous rappelle que pendant les parties
[Musique]
non
oh
à